nous accueillons notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures ce soir mode julie un
bon soir
alors maude julien
séquestrée dans une grande maison
bourgeoise vous avez vécu à l'écart du
monde pendant 15 ans
interdiction de rire de pleurer de se
plaindre sous la douleur de tomber
malade votre père n'avait qu'un but vous
endurcir pour faire de vous un être
supérieur pour que vous deveniez l'élu
cette histoire vous le raconter dans un
livre très touchant publié chez stock
intitulé derrière la grille et à 20h
dans salut les terriens
maud giraud bonsoir vous êtes né le 23
novembre 1957 à lille votre père louis
didier est un chef d'entreprise fortunés
et respecté qui a été initié à d'obscurs
rites maçonniques
en 1936 il a adopté une fillette de 6
ans issu d'une famille pauvre en
imposant aux parents qu'il ne cherche
jamais à la revoir vingt-deux ans après
avoir pris possession de cette femme qui
s'appelle jeanine louis didier décide de
lui faire un enfant cette enfance et
vous mode
trois ans plus tard
louis didier liquide ses affaires et
achète une grande propriété entre lille
et dunkerque
c'est là qu'ils entament la réalisation
de son projet faire de vous un être
supérieur faire d'eux voulait lui
dit que la famille s'installe dans la
propriété vous n'allez plus à la
maternelle c'est jeanine donc votre mère
qui vous fait la classe
l'objectif est de vous préserver de la
pollution des autres
à cinq ans mais même plus droit aux
récréations dans le jardin votre père
vous dit concentre toi sur ce que tu
dois faire
le but de mon père effectivement été de
faire de moi un sur être il avait pour
moi une mission capitale et pour ça il
fallait que j'aie un entraînement
physique et psychique
pour apprendre à justement à ce que
l'esprit soit plus fort que la matière
alors votre maire elle jeanine et
conditionné depuis son plus jeune âge et
elles n'offrent aucune résistance elle
dit monsieur didier peut tout voir un
peu comme dieu qui voit tout ce qu on
fait quoi c'est important de comprendre
que tout ça c'est le système de
l'emprise bien sûr et que les systèmes
de l'emprise c'est quand même un ogre
pour qui seule compte son monde mental
les autres ce sont soit des instruments
en service soit d obstacle absolu alors
votre père donc vous prépare sauver
l'humanité qui selon lui est déchu leur
d'abord ils vous apprendre à contrôler
votre corps avec ce qu'il appelle les
exercices d'impassibilité alors il faut
rester face à lui sans remuer quoi que
ce soit il dit seuls les faibles ondées
expressif et puis les expressions c'est
ce qui va permettre aux autres donc le
moment où il y avait les élus et les
autres les démons et c'est ce qui va
permettre si vos émotions
transparaissent de à ce moment là être à
leur merci et là vous mettez tout tout
le monde en péril voilà alors ce qui est
assez qu'au début vous devez rester un
quart d'heure impassible ce qui est très
compliqué en fait parce qu'on a tendance
à bouger son nez sa bouche et que ça
gratte oui mais voilà mais bien à tous
et plusieurs heures alors haute
faiblesse humaine que votre père ne
supporte pas c'est le plaisir c'est à
dire qu'ils supportent pas besoin les
jours de fête du travail est plus que
les autres jours oui parce que je dirais
les terriens de la vision de mon père
sont
hypnotisés par ces fêtes anniversaires
pour être manipulée donc il faut
absolument résister donc les jours
d'anniversaire les jours de fête si à
double peine pour justement avoir un
effet de réaction de colère contre ces
jours là et pour ces jours là ne pas
risquer de se faire happer par ce monde
alors le travail manuel fait aussi
partie de l'enseignement à deux fois
deux heures par jour devait pousser une
brouette pleine de sable ou alors
transporté avec vos mains des sacs de
bris pas qu'il y avait des chantiers
m'ont pas les affaires des chantiers
chantier dans la propriété voilà vous
êtes vieux c'était important ça devait
faire partie de ma formation alors pour
votre père l'étude de la musique est la
chose la plus importante un édit les
seules personnes qui sont sorties
vivantes et quand des camps c'est les
musiciens et ça on ne peut pas savoir à
l'avancé quels musiciens on aura besoin
c'est pour ça que séduit tu dis à peu
près une dizaine d'instruments de
musique oui parce qu'en fait bon il ya
le piano alors avec la prof de piano ça
va alors le prof d'accordéon par exemple
il est terrible avec vous ils vous
insulte il vous donne des gifles niveau
il vous jette des bières au visage il
écrase ses cigarettes sur votre cuisse
française c'est déjà le qu'il faut
toujours comprendre c'est qu'un système
d'emprise permet la réalisation de
sous-systèmes même vont générer des abus
si je prends l'exemple d'une entreprise
suffit d'un seul
supérieur abusif pour que les salariés
descendent en chaîne se sentent
autorisés agir et penser puissante donc
le système de l'emprise c'est lui qui a
généré tous les autres systèmes alors
par exemple vous apprendre à nager votre
père fait construire un bassin en béton
au fond du parc et à l'âge de 5 ans
s'est jetée par votre mère dans l'eau
froide partant du principe que les
esprits forts sont capables de se
débrouiller donc je dois arriver à me
débrouiller depuis je suis resté
quelqu'un qui déteste nager je comprends
alors votre père ça quand même s'inspire
beaucoup du troisième reich alors il
déteste l idéologie du 3ème reich même
temps il était fasciné par cette
capacité de la façon dont ils formés les
jeunesses hitlériennes
donc il fallait que je sois encore plus
formée que hitler jugend voilà ouais
parce que si ce système revenait il
fallait que je sois capable de résister
à la torture que je sois capable c'était
toujours dans son idéologie de me rendre
plus fortes donc il faut apprendre à pas
dormir les sommeil étant une perte de
temps rires les faibles a pas prendre de
plaisir en mangeant donc on vous donne
du pain rassis
alors parce que l'alimentation
molle c'est pour les faibles et les
mousses et vous savez qui m'a fallu des
années à ne pas culpabiliser en mangeant
guînoise rit oui d'accord un quinze ans
plus tard c'était dès lors le pire parce
que là c'est quand même très dangereux
pour vous c'est apprendre à tenir
l'alcool j'étais à dire qu'à midi vous
buvez un verre de ricard un verre de vin
blanc un verre de rouge un cognac comme
vous mangez très vite parce qu'il faut
pas perdre de temps vous ingurgitez ça à
toute allure et ensuite vous devez être
capable de tenir une homme de marcher
sur une ligne blanche qu'il a tracée
dans le pas c'est l'entraînement alcool
et volonté soit là c'est à dire que là
aussi comme l'esprit doit être plus fort
c'est-à-dire que même sous alcool il
fallait être capable d'être plus forte
que le produit qui est ingérée et là
vous avez 7 en quoi est-ce a commencé
vers l'âge de 7 ans alors bodmer n'avait
pas même de temps en temps en cachette
de votre père un petit geste temps un
petit geste d'affection et le monumental
du coup imposer mon père faisait qu'on
pouvait rien faire en cachette en
cachette il était là et puis à la cab
alors là quand même la caf c'est assez
violent celle qui vous réveille en
pleine nuit vous mais assise sur une
chaise dans une cage toujours pas bougé
mais le but en fait pour cette mission
capitale à laquelle il me vouer je
devais être capable d'apprendre à
circuler entre les univers apprendre à
communiquer avec les morts il ya des
rats tout autour de vous alors moi je
suis plus
phobiques est tétanisé par l'idée d'un
rat qui puisse grimper sur moi que pour
lui à ce moment là les morts je sais
c'est pas ma préoccupation
mais à ce moment là quand même vous
appelez la mort vous préférez y être
mort oui qu'être assis sur cette chaise
dans cette cave au milieu des rats c'est
moins pire il ya le ps de l'électricité
aussi c'est incroyable série vous
demande de tenir un fil électrique de
prendre des charges pendant 10 minutes
quand tu y es la décharge c'est ne pas
réagir ça rentre c'est toujours la même
logique le monde de mon père était très
cohérent un droit logique danse insolite
et quoi on voit là et alors l'intrus
quand même car c'est le service de louis
didier sirgue le matin vous vous lever à
6 heures du matin fait plein de trucs et
ensuite à 8h00 et votre père donc hélas
vous devez tenir son pot de chambre
pendant qu'il urine quand même donc là
c'est quand même j'avais toujours des
nausées et tout avec ses odeurs et
j'avais une sensation de dégoût mais ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que celle
que je reprochais qui se dégoûte est
presque c'était moi de ne pas être
capable comme le plus troublant ce sont
ces cicatrices sur les cuisses sur la
poitrine dont vous ne connaissez pas
l'origine ce sont des rites initiatiques
vous pensez ce qui est certain pour les
médecins c'est qu'elles n'ont pas été
faites par des professionnels de la
santé ce qui exclut la thèse de
l'accident vous ne le saurez jamais et
j'ai bien peur de ne jamais savoir par
là vous pensez à vous suicidez
évidemment parce que bon c'est
insupportable pour l'enfant que vous
êtes et ce qui est bizarre d'ailleurs
c'est qu'il vous laisse lire des tas de
bouquins alors je dois au comte de monte
cristo d'avoir compris que je n'étais
pas folle parce que quand le montecristo
explique ce qu'il ressent dans sa tête
quand il est enfermé mais là mois en
prison il commençait très fort de monter
question est là petit à petit une idée
six ans vous vous demandez et si
finalement mon père n'était pas cet être
supérieur doit de tous les pouvoirs et
peut-être que ce qu'il raconte c'est que
du bla bla bla finalement ita petit à
petit parce que un jour jose un premier
tout petit mensonge c'est ce que
j'appelle les manuels de désobéissance à
lui est c'est à dire je ne me pose pas
lui mais je trahis un tout petit peu son
enseigne et un jour alors que votre père
vous annonce une punition vous attrapez
un couteau et vous vous le planter comme
ça dans la main et vous versez vous même
le whisky sur la plaie en retirant la
lame et en le fixant et l'a finalement
vous dites est ce que c'est parce qu'il
attend de moi c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire parce qu'en fait si vous
a forgé comme ça c'est peut-être pour en
arriver là j'ai croisé son regard et
j'ai vu un éclat de fierté et cette
classe de fierté m'a plongé un coup de
poignard dans l'eure se frayant parce
que j'ai dit mais je suis en train de
devenir qui veut vous profite évidemment
d'être obligé de sortir de la propriété
pour des cours avec sté ailleurs
et quand vous arrivez dehors ça c'est
extraordinaire il vous faut tout
apprendre par exemple comment fait-on
pour dépasser quelqu'un sur un trottoir
alors que d'autres personnes viennent en
face de vous à ce cd chose faite un
jeudi ruby est obligé de rendre tous là
pour rencontrer richard donc votre père
vous dis toute façon dans six mois je te
paierai le divorce et tu reviendras
vivre ici pour accomplir sa mission
alors vous divorce serait beaucoup plus
tard de richard met ensemble vous aurez
deux filles c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle or votre père meurt en 1979
alors évidemment là vous avez le fois
abîmée par l'alcool évidemment bon la
dentition en piteux état parce qu'il
fallait pas aller chez le dentiste
z et et annie des évanouissements des
crises de panique c'est à dire que après
la mort de mon père où je devrais plutôt
être libéré c'est là où il faut
comprendre point l'emprise est avant
tout psychologique
alors ça me disant pour vous
reconstruirez me disant un peu plus de
dix ans pour arriver petit à petit vous
êtes devenu psychothérapeute aujourd'hui
ces thérapeutes oui mais voilà vous
l'avez par demeure sur cette notion du
pardon personne n'a jamais demandé
d'excusés donc en revanche ce qui est
certain c'est que je ne nourris pas de
ressentiment c'est patent mon histoire
qui est importante c'est comment une
petite fille de 8 ans a été capable de
commencer à s'échapper et si une petite
fille de 8 ans était capable de faire ce
que les personnes qui entend autour de
nous qui le gardent espoir parce que ce
qu'une petite fille de 8 ans était
capable de faire d'autres peuvent il est
merci de votre témoignage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu